voici luc ferry
ne tombez pas dans le panneau
ne tombez pas dans le panneau vous voyez
comment luc ferry à part la coupe
j'aime bien moi j'aime bien ses cheveux
comme ça ça me plaît c'est génial parce
qu'elle a quand même refusé marché low
mastroianni et marlon brando h robert de
niro et est donc vous elle vous trouve
bien bon espoir
luc ferry dont vous avez été pendant
deux ans ministre de la recherche de
l'éducation des universités de la
jeunesse jusqu'au 31 mars 2004 où vous
avez été remplacé par françois fillon
qui a beaucoup de problèmes en ce moment
lui aussi un cépage marpa fillon est
plus facile de changer le ministre les
syndicats ça c'est vrai que c'est vite
fait voilà alors aujourd'hui va vous
raconter votre expérience de ministre
dans un livre plaidoyer où se mêlent le
récit de votre aventure et quelques
réflexions philosophiques
ça s'appelle comment peut-on être
ministre c'est publié chez plon
alors on va prendre les choses au début
à l'arrivée quand vous arrivez comme
ministre au départ vous êtes plein
d'enthousiasmé c'est formidable rester
enthousiaste pendant les deux années
parce que c'est vrai que c'est un métier
si j'ose dire vase et peut-être pas un
métier mais une fonction passionnante
messager pas perdu l'enthousiasmé manaf
un oui au départ quand vous arrivez vous
êtes très content vous vous dites ça va
être formidable c'est plein d'idées on
attendait il faut être honnête on crève
de trouille aussi parce que je suis
quand même pas foule très bien que
c'était
mais ni ses deux chiens que saleh est
extraordinairement difficile j'avais vu
quand même les manifs foule claude
allègre ou sous françois bayrou et je
savais bien que serait pas une partie de
plaisir mais c'est vrai que j'avais un
vrai enthousiasme qu'il y avait des
commandes hier des dossiers que je
connaissais qui m'intéressait sur
lesquels je pensais pouvoir faire
quelque chose oui voilà finalement non
on va voir nos rangs un peu plus
compliqué que ça entièrement fouillé les
jeunes tout n'est pas négatif
laurent jamais ce poste là est très
difficile ça l'est de l'asie est mort
c'est fillon il se marre pas là en ce
moment 1 rosenau il s'en va il s'en tire
bien plutôt parce que je crois que c'est
la première grève qui lasse pas énorme
un an quasiment annoncé c'est plutôt pas
mal non
alors vous découvrez rapidement étant
ministre luc ferry que les démocraties
sont moins gouvernable que ne le pensent
les les citoyens et vous dites au fond
les hommes politiques n'ont pas beaucoup
de pouvoir d'ailleurs la preuve c'est
que les grands problèmes sont sont
jamais réglé on ne fait que les
repousser devant comme ça comme un
budget quoi c'est hubert védrine qui me
disait l'autre jour dans les débats sur
la question car si les hommes politiques
ont le pouvoir ou pas disait le métier
politique c'est comme un chirurgien qui
devrait opérer un petit garçon très
malade avec toute la famille autour de
l'ensemble de la presse 3 les avocats de
la famille et quatre tous les confrères
animé commencé par une veine vigilante
et qu'ils vont dire attendez il a la
main qu'il y prendre qu'est ce qui fait
donc c'est un peu ça c'est vrai que
c'est devenu très difficile je pense pas
que les journalistes ou les hommes
politiques soient à égalité sur la
question du courage ou l'est où les
grands patrons je pensais la même chose
tout dépend du taux d'exposition qu'on a
aux emmerdements pour être mans c'est à
dire notamment pardon aux médias alors
c'est vrai vous dites tous les français
sont d'accord pour qu'on fasse des
réformes
sauf quand ça devient négatif pour eux
dire que la pub personnes me faire de
réformes oui on est un peu comme des
enfants chez le dentiste
quand on l'a on n'a pas envie d'y aller
on sait bien regarder la réforme des
retraites moi il fallait que j'annonce à
un million de collègues c'est pour moi
les collègues c'est quand même les
professeurs qu'ils allaient en gros
travailler
trois ans de plus pour gagner à peu près
la même retraite alors que pratiquement
la moitié d'entre eux n'avaient qu'une
envie c'est plutôt de partir trois ans
plus tôt en gagnant plus d'argent donc
c'était dur vous pouvez pas annoncer ça
même si c'est absolument nécessaire et
en même temps avoir des gens qui vous
sourit ou qui sont contents de ce que
vous leur dites donc ça c'est aussi le
métier politique c'est être capable
d'annoncer des choses qui sont pas
toujours agréables pour ça que tout le
monde vous dit tenez bon courage au
début c'est même inquiétant quand tout
le monde avait dit tenez bon courage
vous dîtes surtout quand on retire les
chaînes en même temps alors vous dites
c'est encore plus difficile d'être
ministre quand on vient de la société
civile vous dites parce que le président
ils préfèrent des professionnels qui lui
doivent tout qu'un mec qui arrive de la
société civile qui ne doit rien c'est
vrai qu'on est des électrons libres on
peut dire n'importe quoi dans une
émission de télévision risque rien en
plus de ça parce qu'on est plus
courageux que les autres c'est parce
qu'on risque rien d'une certaine façon
on sait bien qu'on va après votre et
notre métier tandis qu'un type qui a
fait ça pendant 40 ans ou 30 ans et qui
sait que sur une grève il peut perdre
son job et devenir n'importe quoi après
il va évidemment êtes vous plus prudent
que nous c'est normal maintenant il ya
un truc en train d'insulter civile qui
est terrible c'est que au bout de deux
ans on s'en va c'est quand on commence à
apprendre le boulot mais ça c'est un peu
un peu dommage enfin fait partie du jeu
et à manger
alors outre problème c'est terrible
quand on lit votre bouquin on n'a plus
du tout envie d'être d'être minispace
que autre problème les coups bas
c'est à dire quel adversaire évidemment
les coups bas de l'adversaire d'hier en
fait jacques lang vous reprocher une loi
dont il avait été l'auteur d'une
certaine façon oui j'ai défendu pendant
un an devant des étudiants qui étaient
parfois c'est assez opposées en fait des
arrêtés qui avait été signé par jack
lang en avril 2002 juste avant que je
n'arrive et c'est vrai que pendant ce
temps là ils tiraient à boulets rouges
mais ça ça fait partie du jeu aussi ça
me c'est difficile parce que d'une part
il ya les gens qui sont contre vous
comme jack lang et puis vos amis qui
vous savez la planche comme bayrou vous
à vous ça venait 0 1
non mais attendez berrou kivu savane la
planche la meynard d'abord parce qu'il
est dans la majorité présidentielle
et ensuite parce que c'est le parrain 2
d'une deux beaux-fils kamenar mme bayrou
a fait un grand discours sur la réforme
des universités
mais pour dire que je suis en train
d'américaniser l'université de
privatiser l'université ce qui en gros
le discours des étudiants dessus donc
vraiment de gauche alors qu'il est 100%
d'accord avec moi sur le fond et il le
sait très bien
il a quand même été mise des universités
comme ce dossier par coeur bon en même
temps comme ils détestent chirac et que
lille a qu'une envie c'est que le
gouvernement de raffarin se casse la
figure et que moi je réussisse pas là où
bon il a peut-être pas non plus réussi
en tout cas pas à faire ce qu'ils
voulaient il peut pas faire autrement
que tirer quoi c'est pas qui tire tire
je me tiens sur quelqu'un qui dans son
dans son propre camp et qui en plus est
le parrain de sa fille bien que le
showbiz mais je les raconte pas par
méchanceté c'est pas du tout le but du
livre il s'agit pas de régler des
comptes mais c'est pour expliquer
pourquoi
oui tout à fait en effet pour moi c'est
un peu ciblant les politiques c'est mal
raconté c'est très peu mais vous allez
m'aider chers amis ce qui est le plus
terrible que tout ce sont les les
campagnes de presse alors c'est
extraordinaire vous raconter par exemple
cet article du canard enchaîné
on dit que j'avais une nurse paraissent
pas moi mes filles tu te fais langer on
le sait laurent 10 en 10 jours du port
be bon j'en suis au saint mamert fans
ont dit que la soeur de votre femme
habite la maison cuites au magistère
holcim a hélas été des travaux
d'aménagement dans la cuisine c'est vrai
ça mais non si c'est vrai quand même
c'est qu'on a eu un vrai dégât des eaux
de l'électricité à péter parce que le la
résidence du ministère qui était un
endroit souvent sublime c'est sa
partenaire à ruby rose inquiète elle
attend pillon au bureau et qui a donné
son nom pour des raisons qu'on peut
imaginer aux grandes pouvez vous me dire
qu'il ya dans les brasseries parisiennes
exclusion sociale les grands poivrier
s'appelle des rubis rosa vous savez
pourquoi
non je n'ai pas à finir compris ce à
quoi tu as dit rocco dans ta cuisine
mais repoussée pour le sel et puis à la
literie en satin aussi voilà c'est tout
c'est certainement une qualité que c'est
un peu si c'est vrai puisque marie
caroline votre épouse est devenu un peu
comme marie-antoinette quoi c'est à dire
que d'un seul coup on lui reprocher des
trucs tél alors cette literie en satin
surtout on est devenu un peu pas un peu
paranoïaque en fin de parcours mais
comme le disait woody allen on peut être
paranoïaque y avoir des ennemis et bien
compatible et donc c'était un peu les
deux premières fois bon ça c'est
anecdotique mais en même temps sur la
literie en satin luc sérieusement alors
c'est un pur baiser franchement non moi
j'ai une façade s'accroche mais enfin
bon chacun
les bras c'est ridicule
on en convient cros et idem encore
c'était vraiment c'était un cadeau de
mariage
enfin ça pas de sens alors surtout
comment ça peut se retrouver dans le
canard enchaîné vous dites mais enfin
les gens sont fous en plus c'est
surréaliste parce que par exemple j'ai
eu pendant trois semaines
des papiers sur le thème les ferries
roule en rolls saoulé par la seule
voiture au monde dans laquelle je sois
jamais monté il se trouve cela vraiment
pair avec vous ma vie très saine il y
avait la rolls il avait aussi libération
qui parlait de vos costumes à 5000 euros
voilà ça a baissé là on a eu tous armés
et c'est vrai que derrière le côté
complètement anecdotique et sans aucun
intérêt de cette affaire finkielkraut
avait eu une très jolie phrase je trouve
à propos de la sphère clinton il avait
dit je ne savais pas que la presse
mondiale
allez élire domicile dans le slip de
bilfinger n'da c'est un petit peu ce qui
nous est arrivé toutes proportions
gardées choisir mais ces crèmes
désagréable en or et c'est effectivement
moi je connais un petit peu votre votre
parcours
on a écrit que vous étiez un héritier
étiez un brillant normalien alors que
vous venez d'un milieu relativement
modeste père était mécanicien automobile
de génie certes mais était quand même un
mécanicien automobile s'était pas
quelqu'un qui avait qu'avait une fortune
vous avez passé votre enfance à traîner
dans son atelier à la garenne colombes
et vos études vous avez fait votre bac
par correspondance
donc dans le genre héritier c'est vrai
qu'il ya mieux quoi je veux dire ah oui
c'est ça c'est aussi une chose avec
laquelle il faut apprendre à vivre c'est
la dir-ce la distorsion complète qui
entre l'image qu'on donne parfois de
vous et puis la réalité fax il est bon
je préfère me zerbib puis tout le monde
s'en fout mais c'est vrai que si on
savait que par exemple quand on n'allait
pas de salle de bains dans la maison
j'habitais quand on était mômes et donc
quand la légende présentait comme un
stallone a
mondain friqués qui fit qui retirait
l'argent aux malheureux professeur et je
suis j'étais un prof exactement comme
les autres d'ailleurs plus fous de joie
le jour où j'ai passé la grecque et que
j'ai vu que j'étais reçu j'ai tout ça je
l' ai vécu comme les professeurs
quand on dit que vous voulez en rolls
quand on dit vous vous êtes mariés à
saint tropez
alors vous avez jamais rouler en rolls
exact mariés à paris vous vous répondez
aux journaux à ce moment là la vérité
que c'est quand vous faites un
communiqué 1 on vous croit pas mais deux
vous informer tous ceux qui étaient pas
encore enfin il faut faire des absolus
il faut pas il faut pas d'ailleurs mais
à chaque fois je disais c'est encore la
semaine dernière luc ferry a accumulé
les bourdes et les maladresses au
ministère mais qu'est ce qu'ils
appellent des bourdes et des maladresses
c'est simple quand on a le malheur de
dire la vérité c'est tout ouais c'est ça
qui est terrible parce que vous
apercevez que quand vous parlez par
exemple moi j'ai jamais eu de plumes au
ministère personnes n'écrivait mes
discours et pendant un an j'ai pas eu de
directrice de la communication et c'est
inimaginable que j'ai je me rends compte
maintenant qu en effet j'étais un peu
barjot alors vous apparaissez
effectivement j'ai des gens à ce moment
là comme une espèce d'aristocrates coupé
des réalités du peuple ce que vous
n'êtes pas au fond alors c'est là que
c'est là que jacques chirac vous lâche
alors un jour vous aviez alors ce qui
est extraordinaire c'est que vous êtes
avec le conseiller de chirac
c'est sur les questions éducatives et re
cité l'éducation et caetera et et vous
recevez le journal le monde et le titre
si l'elysée à jour le projet de loi
ferris universités il le mec et il
consigne est de chirac pour ces sujets
là qui vient doit lutter pas au courant
non et c'est un type très honnête très
intelligent pour qui j'ai beaucoup
d'estimé et d'affection et je crois
sincèrement qu'il ne m'a pas menti et
qu'il n'était pas au courant donc comme
j'étais à l'elysée j'en ai profité pour
faire ma petite enquête tout le type me
disait mais non c'est une blague du
monde encore les journalistes qui
racontent n'importe quoi maintenant
là il avait tout à fait raison de jours
après un effet je le raconte dans le
livre j'ai reçu un coup de téléphone du
président la république qui m'a demandé
en gros de faire passer le projet doit
tout de suite ce qui n'était pas
possible ou bien de l'enterrer
définitivement ce qui était plus
faisable mais que j'ai beaucoup regretté
cela dit vous ne m'entendrez jamais dire
de mal de lui parce que je déteste
l'ingratitude surtout c'est pas parce
que j'ai peur de la rétorsion c'est
parce qu'au contraire il peut plus rien
faire maintenant si j'avais des choses à
lui dire fais les mains avant
mais bon voilà ce qui se passe entre les
deux je les entends drague d'un
métronome
d'avoir de moins de 35 ans parmi neuf
sérieusement oui si c'était à refaire
oui c'était à refaire à part accepté le
poste de député que que sarkozy vous a
proposé à un moment vous dédaignez un
petit peu à part cette erreur là c'est à
dire d'avoir une légitimité sortie des
urnes
qu'est-ce que vous referiez pas pareil
je pense que là l'erreur que j'ai faite
à coup sûr c'est de ne pas faire en
sorte d'avoir suffisamment d'autorité ou
de pouvoir pour pouvoir dire non à des
choses que je trouve est mauvaise et
peut-être quand on commet dire quand on
n'est pas un vrai politique s'ils vont
me fouetter mais j'espère un vrai
politique mais c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas
suffisamment de pouvoir est en fait vous
avez vous savez même pas ce que c'était
qu'un officier de sécurité où un
chauffeur donc on apprend mille choses
en même temps et franchement dire non au
président de la république s'est pas
c'est pas faim vous avez d'ailleurs même
les vrais politiques
honnêtement le taux de servilité au
conseil des ministres
wima s'est élevé à fait extraordinaire
vous dites les gens font une servilité
géo louis xiv à côté on souhaite saga
l'averse habitants parce que à part
francis mer qui au début on sortait
enfin parler normalement kouame mais
s'est fait reprendre quand même on est
on est un peu un peu terrorisé au
conseil des ministres et même les vieux
pros
même ceux qui ont fait le politique
pendant 30 ans ils peuvent toujours vous
raconter ce qu'ils veulent après or un
conseil mais quand quand le président
est là c'est très calme
sérieusement le vrai risque est votre
principale erreur ça a été de
sous-estimer le poids des idées de 68
dans ce pays parce que d'abord je veux
dire je n'ai fait aucune erreur si elle
est ouverte avec la chemise bleue mais
la cravate rouge après non c'est pas du
tout ça que j'ai dit une chose qui a
rien à voir avec avec l'influent des
soixante huitards sur le système
éducatif je vais vous dire exactement
c'est que quand vous voyez que depuis
les années 20 il ya un déclin faramineux
de la maîtrise de la langue par exemple
dans les années là puisqu'on a eu la
chance de retrouver ça c'est quand même
passionnant dit mills copie de
certificat d'étude des années 23 24 qui
avaient été corrigés il y en a on a
refait passer la dictée
dans les mêmes conditions à des élèves
du même âge et en gros pour aller vite
à l'époque ses cinq fautes vous en
souvenez aller au lycée quand on était
petits c'était cinq fautes 0 c'était est
talonné sur les performances des élèves
aujourd'hui ces 17 fautes mais quand
vous regardez la copie 17 fautes en
moyenne pour des élèves de 5e 10 % des
meilleurs d'entre eux
quand vous regardez la copie ça
ressemble à du texto et donc moi je
disais une chose simple ans et que s'ils
voulaient dans l'éducation il ya à la
fois bien sûr une part de spontanéité et
c'est bien encourager l'imagination des
enfants et tout ça mais il ya aussi une
part d'héritage
c'est que vous n'avez pas ni vous ni moi
inventer la langue française et la
poudre non plus si la poudre la poudre
peut-être mâché pour laquelle mais enfin
la loi française
non mais voilà est donc dans la foulée
dans l'éducation depuis trente ans on
assure valoriser la spontanéité
l'expression des enfants mais en matière
de règles de grammaire la spontanéité
c'est jamais très bon et donc on a
oublié qu'ils avaient aussi des
transmission d'héritage et de patrimoine
qui supposerait une attitude qui est pas
celle du mois je mais l'attitude du
respect à l'égard de traditions qui sont
transmises alors depuis que vous n'êtes
plus ministre
à part bragg et claudia cardinale bravo
à eux dit avant que ça marchait jamais
quand on la drac vous êtes au conseil
d'analysé de la société
ça correspond à quoi ce truc là les soul
et c'est un petit peu comme le service
société d'un grand hebdomadaire c'est le
même principe mais j'ai réuni des gens
qui sont pas des commentateurs de leur
métier ou de leur discipline mais qui
sont des actes par exemple bon y'a pour
le sport il ya david douillet c'est pas
un commentateur du judo et je vous
garantis que pour arriver là où il a été
enfin deux fois champion olympique
champion du monde et c
il faut aussi une immense intelligence
des gens qui sont dans ce conseil
d'analysé son ami s'en sont très bien
mais qu'est ce qu'ils font à quoi ils
sélectionnent les bouchons de radiateurs
de l'eau tout et je vais vous dire j'ai
observé une chose c'est qu'en gros à peu
près la seule réforme qu'on est vraiment
réussi à faire passer quand en tout cas
j'étais dans ce gouvernement c'est la
réforme des retraites et je disais tout
à coup c'était très difficile parce que
en gros on avait ces comme le dentiste
qu'on avait que des mauvaises nouvelles
à annoncer bon et il fallait le faire
quand même je crois est d'ailleurs en
gros le parti socialiste n'avait pas
autre chose à proposer c'est aussi pour
ça que c'est passé mais ce qui a permis
malgré tout de convaincre c'est qu'il y
avait eu avant des comités de condé
conseil des comités etc qui s'étaient
réunis et d'une certaine façon les
élites notamment journalistique savais
qu'il y avait pas autre chose a fait ça
c'est très utile
on a besoin si on veut un jour proposer
des vraies réformes que au moins la
partie éclairée de l'opinion publique
soit formé et donc il faut pas se moquer
des comités théodule parce que souvent
ils font un très très bon
enfin vous avez le groupe sonnerie
légales et éthiques il est quand même de
mauvaise foi problème
alors voilà l'ellipse appel comment
peut-on être ministre luthier
alors maintenant qu'un an viennent plus
min soo et nous dire à quoi ça sert un
ministre alors en gros ça peut préparer
les réformes que fera peut-être son
successeur de ben ca baisse beaucoup et
oui enfin ça dépend lesquels mais parce
qu'il ya des ministères très différents
mais dans un ministère comme le mien
honnêtement c'est 18 heures par jour à
18 h oui vraiment oui c'est bien payé
sérieux n'ont cessé mais c'est mal fait
ou les jeux soient vraiment unir mais on
a supprimé vraiment les fonds spéciaux
les gens me demandaient toujours savez
ce que bon temps il est bon d'accord on
est à dix à la télévision c'est pas vrai
maintenant à bien quand même une petite
pièce non il ya plus de fonds spéciaux
il faut savoir que ça atteignait quatre
cent mille francs par mois et donc sa
belle ministre en fait ce qui veut donc
tout ça a disparu
puis toujours arriver trop sait combien
un ministère il s'est payé combien 40 50
60 francs parce que c'était moins le
premier traitement était encore en
france étaient 78 mille francs voilà
voilà
attendu au un grand patron et ans il
vient combien lui tire ya beaucoup plus
sérieux ça marche et ça marche avec les
filles d'être mini cela ça donne un nom
mais recommencer toujours pas marié avec
la femme la plus belle du monde
quand on est ministre on peut mettre
quelqu'un sur écoute
non non non enfin peut-être je sais pas
moi il faut demander au léger rire mais
le mythe de l'intérieur sûrement mais ça
c'est très très réglementés
enfin l' affaire mitterrand c'est
complètement impossible maintenant
effaré will sasso redirai sari à
l'époque
est ce qu'on doit à l'époque on savait
que ça vous êtes de droite en tout cas
j'ai pas honte de dire que je n'ai
jamais voté à gauche et que je répète
ministre d'un gouvernement de gauche
parce que je compte y avait un côté très
fâcheux aujourd'hui c'est que les gens
de droite sont toujours hyper
culpabilisés par l'associé avec un
surmoi de gouvernement il faut dire les
choses honnêtement je suis centre-droit
c'est pas original je suis pas mort à
droite mais j'ai en tout cas je suis pas